hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday it's another
weekly dev stream so let's get started
with the recap and let's see what we got
for news today so similarly to the past
couple weeks it's going to be another
slow day not entirely a lot or not a lot
of news was talked about basically
though there's going to be the new event
game-mode realistic Dominion we've
already had this in the game before but
just occasionally we're realistic
Dominion is basically regular Dominion
with no gear stats and no gear stand
some widgets so that means you can't see
where the enemy is throwing their attack
you're going to have to go based off of
memory so definitely have fun with that
it's going to be pretty fun I do like
the realistic modes personally myself so
I'll definitely play that when it
launches it's going to be available from
today until March 29th so definitely
want to play that throughout the week
while you can
the new content of the week this week is
going to be new ornaments for the
post-launch Heroes gladiator centurion
Highlander shaman shinobi Inara Musha
they're gonna be 5k steal each if you
want to go pick those up
I'll have the video playing in the
background once again they're nothing
too incredible but they are new
ornaments if you do want to play with
those characters or if you happen to be
like me and have a gladiator like in my
instance I have him as the highest rated
rep for me so I click gladiator a lot so
I may have pick up the arm and I might
not it's entirely up to you if you want
to get it though like I said it's gonna
be 5 case steel next up is the extra XP
fest is going to be starting tomorrow so
Friday I'm assuming all the way til the
weekend so basically Friday through
Sunday there's going to be contract
overs are going to be giving you double
XP matches will give you 50% more XP and
that's going to be the double xp event
so if you have a new character you won't
you've always wanted to try out
definitely go pick that person up and
start grinding it out during double xp
or if you just want to stick with your
old character and increase your rep
score it's entirely up to you you can do
that as well and then the last bit of
news today is basically they're going to
be coming out with the new training
trials and arena mode with the next
coming patch hopefully we'll have a lot
more news on what those are specifically
and a lot and I'd love to talk to you
guys about those when they release and
it's going to be the end of the video
but I'd rather I want to start a
discussion first because this is a very
short video and I want to get you guys
involved in this nothing too crazy I
just want you guys to go to
in the comments below and tell me about
a few things in particular character
reworks and the new trials of training
mode or the arena how do you think it's
gonna work in particular are we gonna be
rewarded with something good for the
arena mode do you think it's useful and
then in terms of the character reworks
what characters need to be worked on and
what in specific I would just like to
know what you guys think on this whole
ordeal but like I did mention that's
going to be the end of the video today
guys thank you offer the love and
support on the past videos even though
there hasn't really been much news I
apologize but it's not I can't really
help it hopefully like I said the trial
training the training trials and the
arena mode should be coming out next
patch so hopefully there'll be a little
bit more details in the stream and stuff
like that subscribe if you're new I
cover the leaks the information the
character details the patch notes the
news everything the informational side
of for honor I like to cover my two most
recent videos gonna be on screen if you
guys didn't miss those and with that
guys hope you have a great rest your day
and peace out